finanzielle entlastungen für alle und es
soll eine nachfolgelösung für das 9 euro
ticket geben im gespräch sind jetzt 49
bis 69 euro
reaktionen man hat gesehen werden dass
neun euro tickets wer alles mit der bahn
fahren kann wohin man überall fahren
kann und das 49 euro auf jeden fall viel
zu viel was sagen sie dazu 18 euro mehr
kindergeld pro kind
kindergeld ist immer gut und besonders
aufgrund der inflation und so weiter ist
natürlich
eine große hilfe ich finde das gut dass
jetzt was für die für die rentner zum
beispiel dabei ist die rim erst in den
ersten paketen vergessen wurden zu
begrüßen ist auf jeden fall nur die
frage sich das den immensen kosten die
auch wiederum auf alle zukommen
22 stunden lang hatten die ampel
koalitionäre am wochenende miteinander
gerungen gestern dann die verkündung
eines weiteren wie es hieß wuchtigen
entlastungspaket
wir haben alle entscheidungen getroffen
die dafür notwendig sind dass wir uns
unterhaken und dass kein bürger und kein
bürger keine bürgerin alleine gelassen
wird die regierung will dafür 65
milliarden euro aufwenden die
schuldenbremse im nächsten jahr trotzdem
einhalten
geplant ist auch eine strompreis bremse
privathaushalte sollen eine gewisse
menge strom zu einem vergünstigten preis
bekommen um das zu finanzieren sollen
energiekonzerne die krisenbedingt hohe
gewinne machen zur kasse gebeten werden
so olaf scholz gestern im zdf
sommerinterview das
erste ist dass wir die zufalls gewinne
die jetzt auf dem strommarkt erzielt
werden abschätzen so genannte über
gewinne von unternehmen ab einer
bestimmten erlös grenze zu besteuern
hatte die fdp immer abgelehnt doch nun
ist die rede von zufalls gewinnen die
nicht besteuert sondern abgeschöpft
werden sollen und der finanzminister
verteidigt dass es ist keine steuer und
es ist auch nicht für allgemeine zwecke
einsetzbar sondern es wird eine erlös
bremse geschaffen und das geld wird
eingesetzt um einen grundbedarf an strom
für die bürgerinnen und bürger und eine
entlastung für die betriebe zu
organisieren nicht ausreichend seien die
entlastungen die sieht die union für die
mittelschicht sowie für betriebe tour
die regierung zu wenig man hätte mehr
tun müssen für diejenigen die so eben
gerade oberhalb der grenzen liegen und
für die betriebe für den mittelstand für
die einzelhandelsunternehmen die
wirklich an der existenzgrenze stehen
die wirklich jetzt mit dem rücken zur
wand stehen wird in diesem papier so gut
wie nichts aufgeschrieben das dritte
entlastungs paket der bundesregierung
noch steht vieles nur auf dem papier
beim vergünstigten nahverkehrsticket
etwa bedarf es noch der zustimmung der
bundesländer
ja hören wir uns an wie die größte
oppositionspartei das entlastungspaket
bewertet ich begrüße den unions
fraktionsvize hans spanischen guten
morgen schon guten morgen hallo ersparen
sie haben schon am wochenende gesagt das
paket sei zu vage was genau meinen sie
damit nun wenn man das einfach mal
durchliest das aufgeschrieben ist dann
ist das ja mehr ein arbeitsprogramm für
die regierung als wirklich ein sofort
wirksames entlastungsprogramm strompreis
bremse ist gut aber keiner weiß bei
welchem preis keiner weiß wann sie in
kraft tritt nachfolgeregelung 9 euro
ticket wird beschrieben man will was tun
ob was wann wie kommt ist völlig offen
und es gibt noch große lehrstellen das
drängendste problem für die meisten
bürgerinnen und bürger ist der hohe
gaspreis da wird eine expertenkommission
eingesetzt die bürger werden vertröstet
also es gibt in der reihe von wahrheiten
von konkreten die am ende mich eben
sagen lassen die summe die man den raum
stellt die klingt ganz gut aber wenn man
genau hinschaut bleibt wenig übrig auf
der anderen seite muss man sagen viel
konkretes ist trotzdem auch dabei 300
euro energie pauschale für rentner 200
euro einmalzahlung für studierende
höherer regelsatz in der grundversorgung
mehr wohngeld mehr kindergeld also es
ist ja beides da ist schon auch konkret
ist dabei finden sie diese konkreten
maßnahmen richtig und gut die konkreten
maßnahmen sind ohne zweifel richtig aber
sind halt zu wenig und auch zu wenig
fokussiert
ich hätte lieber 1000 2000 euro für
menschen mit kleineren mittlerem
einkommen als jetzt wieder 300 euro für
alle rentner wenden und rentner ist also
nicht besonders zielgerichtet und für
eine vierköpfige familie die mit
zweieinhalb tausend euro netto hinkommt
die gerade echt mit diesen hohen
energiepreisen ist sehr sehr schwer hat
die kriegt dann für die beiden kinder 36
euro im monat das ist die ganze
unterstützung und die gehen gerade in
einer sehr sehr schwierigen winter
hinein also ja da sind einige
vernünftige maßnahmen drin aber nur
einen schritt zurücktritt und auf den
gesamtansatz schaut ist es nicht
besonders zielgerichtet und da wo es mal
was konkretes geben könnte werden nur
überschriften gesetzt sie haben eben
eine gaspreis bremse angesprochen oder
dass man was gegen den hohen gaspreis
machen sollte beim strompreis ist die
koalition das jetzt angegangen mit einer
art strompreis bremse was können sie
sich vorstellen in sachen gaspreis nun
die idee eines grundbedarfs für jeden
haushalt der ist ja vor allem eigentlich
beim gas diskutiert wurde was man also
sagt es gibt eine bestimmte menge gas
den durchschnitts haushalt verbrauchte
im winter um die wohnung zu wärmen zu
heizen die kostet weniger die wird
entsprechend unterstützt es gibt im
planbarkeit für familien oder eben auch
für mittelständische betriebe im
einzelhandel in der gastronomie hat sich
für viele die vorauszahlung verdreifacht
vervierfacht dass man dort eben für die
unternehmen entsprechende unterstützung
schafft jetzt mit einer
expertenkommission eingesetzt ich würde
vermuten für diesen winter wird das
nicht mehr viel helfen was übrigens ganz
besonders helfen würde in der zeit wo
die preise für energie hochsitzes mehr
angebot also das ist ja eine debatte den
ganzen sommer nichts entschieden
kernkraftwerke kohlekraftwerke biogas
eigentlich müssten wir in der zeit wie
dieser alles und das schon seit monaten
nutzen an energie erzeugung was wir in
deutschland haben und dazu ist gar
nichts aber wirklich gar nichts in
diesem papier auch das würde die preise
stabilisieren beim strom soll der staat
künftig sogenannte zufalls gewinne
abschöpfen können das erinnert sehr an
die ohren die umstrittene idee einer
über gewinn steuer wie stehen sie dazu
ich bin jetzt erstmal gespannt auch da
ist es ja sehr vage und unkonkret was
denn zufalls gewinne sind wie die also
über allein der begriff was was heißt es
denn zufalls gewinnen wie definiert man
das und wie wird das abgeschöpft es gibt
einen punkt der ist ja richtig dass etwa
auf dem strommarkt dadurch dass die
gaskraftwerke gerade sehr teuer strom
produzieren den preis setzen dass es für
jemanden der eine photovoltaikanlage hat
oder wer wie ein konzern kohle kraftwerk
betreibt der macht gerade unerwartet
viel gewinn aufgrund dieser knapp heitz
lage da ein teil abzuschöpfen und
dadurch die entlastung zu finanzieren
das ist grundsätzlich sicher
vernünftiger an gang aber ob wann und
wie das kommt auch dazu findet man in
dem papier nichts sie haben die mögliche
nachfolge für einen neuen euro ticket
eben angesprochen das ist noch kein
konkreter punkt ob es jetzt 29 oder 49
euro kosten wird aber was würden sie
entscheiden was würden sie machen finden
sie ein nachfolgeprojekt des neuen euro
tickets nötig in diesen zeiten es ist
grundsätzlich vernünftig sicherlich ein
bundesweit einheitliche regelung zu
haben wir haben viele unterschiedliche
tarifgebiete das ist schon sehr
verwirrend und auch ein preis zu haben
der attraktives nur bei all diesen
themen hat man halt bisher nicht mit den
ländern gesprochen also wenn sie steuern
senken wenn sie bei der umsatzsteuer was
machen oder bei der einkommenssteuer
oder eben einen neuen euro ticket
nachfolgeregelung brauchen dann müssen
die länder mitmachen weil die
finanzieren das mit die organisieren
dass und deswegen hätte es eigentlich
vor diesen entscheidungen auch in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz geben
sollen geben müssen das haben wir in
einer anderen vorherigen krise
regelmäßig gesehen dass bund und länder
sich gut und intensiv austauschen das
fehlt hier also es wird auch viel geld
verteilt das eigentlich ländern und
gemeinden vom ansatz her beim
steueraufkommen zu steht da muss man
halt auch miteinander reden reaktionen
waren das auf das dritte
entlastungspaket vom vize
fraktionsvorsitzende der union jens
spahn vielen dank sehr gerne